today marks one month since russia
began its carnage in ukraine the brutal
invasion of ukraine
and uh we held a nato summit the very
next day
at that time my overwhelming objective
and wanting that summit
was to have absolute unity on three key
important issues among our nato and
european allies
first was
to support ukraine
with military and humanitarian
assistance
second was
to impose the most significant the most
significant sanctions economic sanction
regime ever
in order to [ __ ] putin's economy and
punish him for his actions third was to
fortify the eastern flank of our nato
allies who were obviously
very very concerned and somewhat at
worried what would happen
we accomplished all three of these and
today we're determined to sustain those
efforts
and to build on them
the united states is committed to
provide over two billion dollars in
military equipment to ukraine since i
became president
and i air systems and my armor systems
ammunition
and our weapons are flowing into ukraine
as i speak
and today i'm announcing the united
states are prepared to commit
more than one billion dollars in
humanitarian assistance to help get
relief to millions of ukrainians
affected by the war in ukraine
many ukrainian refugees will uh will
wish to stay in europe closer to their
homes
but we also will welcome 100 000
ukrainians to the united states with a
focus on reuniting families
and we will invest 320 million dollars
to bolster democratic resilience
and defend human rights in ukraine and
neighboring countries
we're also coordinating
with the g7 and the european union on
food security as well as energy security
and i'll have more to say about that
tomorrow
we're also announcing new sanctions
of more than 400 individuals and
entities aligned with in alignment with
the european union
more than 300 members of the douma
oligarchs and russian defense companies
that fuel the russian war machine
in addition to the 100 000 us forces now
stationed in europe to defend nato
territory
nato established as you already know
four new battle groups from romania
hungary bulgaria and slovakia to
reinforce the eastern front
putin was banking on nato being split
my early conversation with him in
december in early january it was clear
to me he didn't think we could sustain
this cohesion
nato has never never been more united
than it is today
putin is getting exactly the opposite
what he intended to have as a
consequence of going into ukraine
we've built that same unity with our
european the european union and with the
leading democracies of the g7 in the g7